quite often when you hear therapists
talking about people going through the
grieving process they say that there's a
the anger stage the denial stage the
depression stage the bargaining stage
and finally the acceptance stage most
people in this country voted to leave
the EU and I think some of the Romanians
are still at the anger and denial stage
there is a very clear set of ideas as to
what we do next the good Lord may not
like them but I think there are
perfectly good arguments in that
document which I'd be happy to send you
to explain what issues we can do next
Douglas can I say that this argument
about bereavement is one of the most
patronizing statements i have ever
perfect three sacks on icing to the 52
no sense look Pete can I also be clear
about this fifty two percent we have a
democracy where you accept that there is
a process you accept that that means
that when it goes against you you do not
start refusing to pay your taxes you do
not have a right to violent or rather
than unpeaceful demonstrations but on
the day after a Labour government is
elected Tory Party activists and MPs
decide the very next day that their main
aim in life is to make sure that at
least within five years that is reversed
and the idea that they should go into
Parliament and vote with the Labour
government because that is accepting the
will of the people is absurd I
completely accept as a given fact that
you're going to leave that you're ready
in good have you should I am completely
accept that we are going to leap well
when you say is good at you accept that
supplies that I wasn't gonna live object
that we shouldn't accept it what Liz
seems to suggest that we shouldn't took
what I am suggesting is that if it
occurred over the next year that there
was a turn of events by which on
februari the 21st next year we had a
referendum that went 52 to 48 sent the
other
that would be equally legitimate as the
one that went 52 to 48 things that
though second referenda look only think
there is almost no chance of that
occurring but to suggest that it's
somehow illegitimate and undemocratic
for some people to want that suggests
the names only really understand
democracy having be okay 33 come back
and then I bring another view comments
my lord knows I've been elected there
not because I've been appointed that
anyone Daniel voted for the government
in power whichever it was did you now
that was your interpreter a bunch of
Parliament through the ballot box my
lord not for appointment okay let me
bring in other people let me bring in
other people you'll have a chance to
come back